Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas
has temporarily blocked The subpoena
which would force Republican senator
Lindsey Graham to have to testify in
Georgia in that 2020 election fraud
election fraud
investigation why is this notable well
it's notable because Clarence Thomas is
married to Ginny Thomas and Jenny Thomas
is an extraordinarily prominent election
denier who was in touch with all sorts
of folks involved with the January 6th
Insurrection in no sensible uh country
on no sensible planet in no logical
Universe would Clarence Thomas be able
to make decisions related to anybody and
anything connected with that election
and indeed that is what is going on CNBC
reports Supreme Court Justice Clarence
Thomas temporarily blocks Senator
Graham's subpoena from Georgia grand
jury remember Georgia is the state in
which Donald Trump said I need 11 000
votes give me a break try to coerce
Florida I'm sorry Georgia officials
um into finding the votes that he needed
in order to win that state and I know
that we are days away from the 2022
midterms but yes this was all in the
2020 presidential election the CNBC
article adding uh the Fulton County
grand jury investigating possible
criminal interference in the 2020
election in the state by former
president Trump and allies including
Graham Trump had pressured Georgia's top
election officials to find him
enough votes to overturn the win by Joe
Biden a federal appeals court last week
refused a request by Graham to delay The
subpoena how on Earth is Clarence Thomas
still allowed to rule on anything even
remotely related to the 2020 election
never mind this particular case the
husband of a major denier of the actual
results of that election
arguably Jenny Thomas what do we call
her a January sixer
I I think that is probably the most
logical uh term to use
has the ability to block a subpoena
related to the very lies perpetrated
which deny the validity of George's
election
which his wife was doing
utterly absurd
then as far as Lindsey Graham goes have
we seen anyone short of Donald Trump
himself work this hard not to testify
now I'm gonna say something and it we
have to take it in context what happened
to if you're innocent you have nothing
to worry about now listen I understand
and I know many of you understand that
it makes sense to get a lawyer if you
can afford one
of course I I would also uh take a
lawyer's advice and if it made sense to
try not to testify or to plead the fifth
of course I would do it but it is this
very same right wing that has insisted
previously
if you're innocent you should have
nothing to hide you should have no
reason to plead the fifth you should
have no reason to try to ignore or get
out of responding to a subpoena it is
they who have made that case all along
and it is those very same people who
were taking a different approach now
when it comes to them we saw the trumps
including Donald Trump himself plead the
fifth in a number of different
depositions and in different
circumstances when it was Trump who said
the mob pleads the fifth
you don't need to do that if you're
innocent all of Hillary's people who
pled the fifth clearly are guilty
because pleading the fifth is a sign of
guilt now they're doing it uh and so of
course reasonable people understand
you get the most competent counsel you
can to represent you the most competent
Council you can find or can afford
there's no question about that but they
are the ones who have been saying listen
when people don't have anything to hide
you just show up you say what you know
and that's it now if you confront them
with that now they would say no no no
but sir that applies in normal
situations these are partisan witch
hunts meant to get around
the uh proper use of the justice system
to weaponize that very just and so these
are extenuating circumstances where of
course if this was a normal situation we
would just testify we would never plead
the fifth they will always have such an
excuse but understand at the end of the
day they are hypocrites all of their
principles small government
less regulation
allowing states to make decisions
just showing up and cooperating with law
enforcement all of those things are only
principles they State when it is
convenient for them it's now
inconvenient and now Clarence Thomas
helping out Lindsey Graham albeit
potentially only temporarily